This video is made possible by Vin.
Sarah Watches luxury handcrafted watches at fair prices.
You can check them out through the link below.
Okay.
He was the most hated among Hitler's inner circler thuggish bully who's uncouth
ways and scheming.
Self-Interest allows him to manipulate his way into a position of power within
the Nazi hierarchy has it less personal secretary,
he became the fewer as gatekeeper and just most trusted confidant.
In today's biographics,
we're examining the life and the death of Martin Bormann.
Martin Bormann was born into the Prussian town of Vagal Oban on June the 17th
1900 his parents,
Theodore and Antonio were of the Lutheran faith with Theodore being a post
office workout.
It was his second marriage and he already had two children when Martin came
along.
When Martin was three years of age,
his father,
he died.
Antonia soon remarried.
The child showed little interest in his schooling and in his early teens.
He dropped out to study it and agricultural grade high school.
Those studies,
they were caught short when he signed up with the army.
Upon reaching the age of 18 he joined the 55th field artillery regimens as a
gunner.
He was too late to see any action during the first world war seven garrison duty
until he was discharged from the army.
In February of 1919 Boldman moved to Micklin Borg where he secured a position as
a farmer state manager.
He also joined a volunteer group known as the fry call,
which was formed to to guard the local funds from pillaging.
The group also fought against those that were considered betrayers of Germany
during the war.
The Communists Bowman was now a stocky,
belligerent young man as he quickly learns the trade of the bully.
On March the 17th 1924 Boardman was found guilty of being an accomplice to the
murder of a fellow fry core member named Walter Katto.
Katto was believed to have grossed in another member to the French authorities
for conducting sabotage operations.
That man was subsequently executed by the French in retaliation bombing and
several others.
Got a hold of Catalans.
Took him to an isolated field where they beat him and cut his throat.
Boardman spent a year in prison for the crime being released in February of 1925
he wrote sounds of the farm job in Micklin.
Buggins also joined a paramilitary off shoot of the Nationalist Socialist
Workers Party known as the Front Barn.
Okay.
In May of 1926 [inaudible] left the farm and moved in with his mother.
Read Uber Weimar 99 to 27 he joined the Nazi party proper.
He obtained a job with a weekly newspaper which was edited by Nazi party
official.
Before long Bowman was acting as press manager for the Nazi party in the state
of Thuringia.
There was soon to discover however that he lacks the public speaking ability for
the position and he was transferred to the position of business manager.
In 1928 Borman moved to Munich where he works for the essay insurance office.
At that time,
the Nazi party had set an insurance scheme to come the members who were injured
in clashes with other political groups.
This was necessary because existing insurance companies,
they refuse to come to the Nazis.
Bowman was instrumental in setting up the internal insurance scheme.
It required each party member to pay a premium payouts to injured parties.
They were solely at the discretion of Bowman himself.
The position of power.
This came with holding the purse strings for insurance payouts allowed Bowman to
establish a reputation as a financial expert among Nazi party members.
It also caused many who received pals to feel personally indebted to him well in
September.
The second is 1929 bolden married 19 year old gut.
A Bush ghetto was the daughter of a key Nazi official who was responsible for
settling disputes within the party of Hitler was regularly in attendance at the
Bush House.
Since he was a witness at a wedding,
it was through the Bush connection.
The Bowman was able to come onto the fewer as radar.
On January the 30th 1933 Hitler became chancellor of Germany.
There's men that the various departments of the Nazi party became absorbed into
the state system.
As a result of woman suddenly found himself about a work he approached Hitler's
deputy Rudolph Hess in search of a job has made him his personal chief of staff.
He proved himself to be a valuable asset working behind the scenes to iron out
bickering within the party.
He also took care of mundane routine and organizational duties,
allowing us to focus on public relations and future planning.
As he worked tirelessly on bureaucratic manners,
Borman took every opportunity to get close to Hitler by doing so,
he was building up his own personal power in the summer of 1935 he took
advantage of an opportunity to increase his standing with Hitler when the fury
decided that he needed to upgrade his holiday retreat at Berchtesgaden.
Boardman was given the job of overseeing the remodeling work.
He was determined to bring the job in ahead of schedule in order to score points
with headlines.
As a result,
he pushed the workers relentlessly and the job was completed incredibly quickly.
Hefner was pleased with the work,
but he had another demand.
They were to be no neighbors on the mountain and it was up to Borman to get rid
of them.
Most of them were simply able to be bought off,
but those who refused at their property confiscated and was sent to a
concentration camp.
Then when headline complains that there was no shade at his new retreat,
Borman rush to have they linden tree brought in and planted in the pouring rain
head was beginning to view him as a man who could be relied upon to get things
done.
There is efficiency,
hardwork,
reliability and absolute loyalty.
Boardman and Hitler's trust,
he was entrusted with the job of overseeing Hitler's finances and sat out to the
adult Hitler endowment of German Industry.
This was a ruse to force industrialists to provide gifts that ended up lining
the pockets of the Nazi hierarchy with schemes like this.
He owns the gratitude of Nazi top brass because he always stayed in the
backgrounds.
Bowman was not seen as a threat to Hitler's henchmen who are constantly jostling
among themselves for power.
In fact,
for them it was easy to focus only on his inadequacies.
He was far from physically imposing being a rather squat heavy set man.
He liked any of the sophistication required to be a top player.
Having neither the strength of personality,
all the speaking ability to persuade others,
all of those who simply wrote him off.
We'd come to regret this underestimation.
Perhaps the best insights we haven't.
Mormons character comes from Hitler's or I commit to stuff.
Oms and war production,
Albert Speer and is 1970 book inside the Third Reich says the following,
most of the powerful men on to hip low watched each other jealously like
pretenders to the throne.
This none of them recognize the threats in the shape of trustee.
Bowman,
he had succeeded as representing himself as insignificance while imperceptibly
building up his best eons.
Even among so many ruthless man,
he stood down to buying his brutality and coarseness and the culture which might
have put some restraints on him,
and in every case he carried out what type of Hitler had ordered or what he
himself had gathered from hitless hints a subordinate by nature.
He treated his own subordinates as if he were dealing with cows and oxen.
Borman suddenly tried to control his own immediate boss,
Rudolph Hess.
He would only allow others to access has if he,
one of his staff members were presence.
In March of 1938 Hitler returned to his home country of Austria.
Borman accompanied him with a special task to perform.
Hedler told him to buy up his Hitler's childhood home along with the school that
he had attended.
This is something Bowman did successfully a month later and organized a special
presence of the fear to celebrate the neatest 50th birthday high in the mounds,
NC bill's a tea house for Hipaa.
It costs some 30 million marks as treasurer of the Nazi pass.
Bowman was extremely liberal and dishing out money.
He gave 50,000 bucks each month to the SS for entertainment expenses.
Nothing was too much trouble for hitting his girlfriend Eva Braun.
Bowman would order silk underwear,
perfume,
and jewelry from Paris despite his lavish spending on behalf of others,
Bowman was not so popular among Hitler's in a circle.
In fact,
most people,
they detested him.
He had no friends to speak of and treated those under him with a British
dominance that made onlookers recoil.
Now,
just before we get into the main event today,
which is of course the war.
I wants to take a moment to tell you about Vince.
Sarah watches,
look,
and here's the truth,
yet they need a watch.
You've got to phone,
you can check the time,
see that easily anytime you want.
But here's the thing about watches today,
they're not really about telling the time.
It's all,
they're more kind of like jewelry for many of the men who don't really wear
jewelry like myself.
I need wear a wedding band and a watch.
So I love having a good looking watch.
It's,
I've,
I've in fact a few to choose from.
It's something about style.
It's a statement about you and what you like and that sort of thing.
And in a way for me,
it's sort of a connection to the past.
I mean to all those great people do,
we'll wristwatches they didn't have iPhones to check ins.
I,
I quite liked that historical connection.
Right now I'm wearing even Sarah Chronograph,
uh,
as well as keeping perfect time.
It's also got a timer,
those three back down,
right?
I'll just do a close up B roll shot right here,
but they don't look good.
They also serve a function.
I mean,
yes,
your iPhone also has a timer that it doesn't look this good thing.
It does it.
Now I pick down to watch with a blue and silver combination,
but there's loads of options on their website.
You'll be sure to find something that suits your personal style.
Unlike many other watches on the markets.
Then salary,
clearly it's not about minimalist style.
That's more about that classic good look of a watch.
Like I say,
to me,
I like that historical connection.
So here's the thing.
Many of us,
we could wear tee shirts and sweatpants to work if we wanted to,
but we choose not to.
We wear a shirt.
We up our game just because we can integrate.
Ways to do that is with INSERRA watch.
Go check out the full range below this video,
through the link in the description and thanks to Vince area watchers for
sponsoring.
Let's get into the war.
Showery.
When war broke out in September of 1939 Hitler insisted the Bowman was always
close by.
Ready to do his master's bidding.
His role was as deputy to the deputy fuhrer,
Rudolf Hess and the chief of staff of the fear.
A headquarters here effectively became a middle man between the fear and the
next level down of the Nazi hierarchy.
In May of 1941 Bowman's star,
it was suddenly and unexpectedly elevated.
Rudolf has Hitler's trusted deputy and head of the party chancellery deserted to
Scotland by playing in order to open peace negotiations with the Antis
headlight.
He was outraged at the betrayal of Hess.
He had a number of colleagues of house arrested as the deputy to the trader.
Bowman would have been in danger himself.
He did everything he could to distance himself from Hassey,
even tormented has his wife trying to get her evicted from our home.
It was only when she appealed to head blood by way of Eva Braun that the cold
called and off with the loss of house.
There was now an open position at the very top of the Nazi hierarchy and Hitler
was all too willing to allow Bowman to step into it.
Baldwin was now closer to Hipaa than ever.
He became the fewer is constant shadow,
always walking,
a few steps behind,
but always presence.
As far as Hitler's personal view of bombing goes.
Spare relates that he considered him to be a rogue.
It's a Philistine Stein,
but he went on to say that he didn't have anyone more efficient,
so they had quoted Hitler is saying,
I know he will carry out every order right down to the last detail and see it
through to the end.
Boardman was genuinely convinced that Hitler was Geminis Salvation.
As a result,
he was completely dedicated to the fulfillment of the viewers goals.
As the war in the east progressed,
he became the gatekeeper for the generals in the access to Hitler.
Before reporting to the [inaudible].
They would have to brief Bowman who would then tell them what not to reveal.
To hit that we'll hit let's look is water.
The nations of Europe Bowman way interest his own wall within Germany,
his enemy with the challenges of Christiandom,
he stated that National Socialism and Christianity are irreconcilable and
proceeded to close churches and arrest priests,
so it will,
as it became increasingly powerful.
Bowman actively works to hold back the careers of others who were a part of
headless in a circle,
including Gehring gobbles and him not.
His tentacles reached into every area of the regime,
including the VM ox where he actively encouraged young offices to spy on the Su
is woman's dance to you towards the enemies of the state.
The Jews and Eastern European Slavs was straight down to the party line.
They were useful false labor,
but over and above that they would just better off dead.
He was also opposed to education is claiming that every educated person is a
future enemy.
By 1943 Bowman was more than simply a shadow to the [inaudible].
He was also a subtle manipulator,
fiercely guarding access and guiding Hitler towards the policies that he most
favored as one as a master manipulator.
Martin Bormann was a terrible womanizer.
His marriage was still in tact with his wife,
eventually bearing him 10 children.
However,
he also had a string of mistresses and fathered numerous other children.
He viewed it as his duty to the German Reich to produce as many offspring as
possible.
In 1943 Bowman fell madly in love with an actress named Manya barons.
He decided that seeing her on the side wasn't enough and z wanted to have as his
second wife.
As a result,
he wrote a letter to his actual,
I've gutted telling her about his latest conquest.
It red.
I've fallen madly in love with her and took her against all her resistance.
Now she's mine and his,
I'm a lucky fellow.
I feel incredibly happily married twice over now.
I must take double and triple cad that I stay healthy.
You know,
Martin,
his desire to live a polygamous life was backed up by the Nazi belief that
people of good German stock should sow their seed as liberally as possible.
Gutta something have no say in the matter.
When it came down to the final solution to the Jewish question,
the euphemism used for the mass killing of the Jews.
Borman made sure that it was never openly discussed.
On one occasion when hemlock telephones and with a report that 20,000 Jews had
been eliminated in a week needing the set target Bowman,
he became furious,
admonishing him lets you never discuss such things over the phone.
In 1943 Bowman was appointed as personal secretary.
We things beginning to fall apart as far as the war was concerned.
The fury needed Bowman's blinds loyalty more than ever.
There was grilling discontents within the Nazi ranks and Bowman.
He was determined to weed it out.
On July the 20th 1944 an attempt was made to kill Hitler in its wake Bowman.
He sprung to life firing off taxes in order to mobilize the retaliation.
Swift justice was enacted with more than 200 people being convicted and
subsequently execute it.
Some of these executions,
they were films for Hitler to view it is leisure.
The assassination attempt gave head let the opportunity to crack down on
everyone who opposed him under the direction of Borman.
More than 20,000 people would be executed all sent to concentration camps over
the next nine months for lack of loyalty to the Fiera hydro him load.
The leader of the SS was the final barrier between Bowman and hiphop,
then promoted him to the position of Supreme Ami leader.
However,
with the allies now driving towards Berlin on two fronts,
it was a promotion of dubious merit.
Borman had maneuvered things to bring about the promotion,
seeing it as a means to sideline him lot.
By early 1945 Borman was at the height of his power having negated the power of
him like he was now second only to add off Hitler.
By now.
The writing though it was well and truly on the wall,
the Third Reich,
it was doomed and even bomb new ed.
Yeah.
On January the 16th 1945 Hitler and his inner circle,
they moved underground.
The fear.
Rebecca was located under the gardens of the Reich chancellor rebuilding in the
center of Berlin.
When his oldest son,
Martin,
sent him a letter in March of 1945 asking if he thought the war could still be
one.
He replied that even a dying lion could still strike out with its paws with the
Russians and the Americans.
Closing in on Berlin.
Borman sent out constant messengers for the troops to fight on.
He wrote now the capable will be distinguished from the incapable.
The born elders have smashed all obstacles and dart supremely ready for action.
What would have made plans to fly Hitler out of Berlin on this 56th birthday?
April the 20th 1945 but Hitler refused to leave the bunker.
That very often in the bunker was rocked for the first time by Soviet bombing,
loyal to the very ends Bowman,
right the following and his diary.
During those last days in the bunker,
we will stand and fall with the Fiera loyal onto death.
On April the 29th Barman became a signatory to hit plus last will and testament
had lower also named him as executer of the estate.
That evening,
Hitler married eve abroad the next day.
Then you knew I had just committed suicide in accordance with the fear is
instructions.
Bowman was named party minister making him the highest ranking Nazi left alive.
Admiral Karl Donitz was appointed as the new president of Germany with Berlin.
Now in the grip of the enemy and allied radio station announced that hemlock was
undertaking peace negotiations and outraged.
Bowman.
He wrote the following.
Others believe they must act out of superior understanding.
They sacrifice the Fiera shame on them.
They're honor is disloyalty.
Woman called an emergency meeting of the top ranking men that were left in
Berlin when the brother in law of Eva Braun general failed and didn't show
Borman became furious yelling that he was to be hunted down and arrested.
Fagin was found drunk and in the company of a woman who was not his wife in his
luggage was found foreign currency.
He was returned to the bunker,
runs,
executed on Bowman's orders.
Born left the bunker on May the first he was accompanied by three others.
Their challenge was to break through the Soviet and sacraments of the inner
city.
They made their way to a Uba and tonight,
which they used to get to the spree river.
Bowman was hiding behind a tank when it was hit by artillery fire.
This knocked him to the grounds.
The group eventually made it across the river.
One of them,
the Hitler youth leader,
our taxman separated from the others accident soon Sora Sovia patrol,
so he retraced his steps looking across to where the others had been.
He saw two bodies on a bridge.
He later identified one of them as being Martin Bormann.
Later Ray Red Army lefthanded general claims that he had been brought to the
diary of Martin Bormann,
which had been found lying in the street by the same bridge.
That's when men were sent to the area,
his body.
It was not found.
27 years later.
In 1972 the remains of two men were found by construction workers and a station
in West Berlin dental checks were said to confirm that one of them was Martin
Bormann.
However,
the dentist was working from memory off to a quarter of a century which costs
stouts on the accuracy of his analysis.
However,
the body also has a collarbone injury,
which was consistent with an accidents that Bowman had sustained in 1939 but
it's got us in Salsa Med glass fragments in their jawbones,
which would have been consistent with them having taken cyanide.
The West German authorities deems these three pieces of evidence sufficient
enough that they announced that Martin Bormann was dead.
The death was confirmed in 1998 when DNA testing was done on fragments of the
skull.
11 years later,
the remains of Martin Bohman hit us shadow wiscat it and the Baltic Sea.
It's already,
have you found that video?
Interesting.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up below.
Don't forget to subscribe.
Hit that notification bell.
So you find out when we put out a new video also,
or that's Jack off in Sarah watches,
you'll find a link to them below.
And as always,
thank you for watching.